the impact of the outbreak can also be
felt on Capitol Hill Georgia congressman
Doug Holland is one of several
Republicans who have decided self
quarantine after coming into contact
with an affected person at CPAC joining
us now live from his home is our
headliner this morning ranking member of
the House Judiciary Committee and Senate
candidate Doug Collins appreciate your
time this morning
appreciate you skyping in considering
you are staying in why did you decide to
do that we did so out of a bunch cause
it's good to see you though and because
we came in contact it's been two weeks
ago today in fact today is my last day
I'll be back out tomorrow I'm
asymptomatic I don't have any I've never
had any symptoms of the virus but what
we wanted to do was make sure it four
out of abundance of caution stay in and
emphasize to everyone if they follow the
rules they follow the protocols that are
set out that we can manage this virus
and we can do what is right and I think
by doing this we're setting the example
to say others don't take it lightly take
it seriously but also don't panic make
sure you're doing the right things
washing your hands staying away if
you're sick and if you are sick go to
the doctor and get tested yeah a very
important advice and we're certainly
concerned about your health and the
health of all lawmakers staff everyone
around the country obviously but this is
also happening in a context where in the
last moment we've just gotten a new
statement from senator Ted Cruz he's
also been self quarantined as you know I
believe in Texas he's now saying that
his DC office is going to close
temporarily senator Romney has done the
same there's at least one case of
somebody who's tested positive for
coronavirus in the office of democratic
senator maria cantwell so it's happening
in that context as congressman while
Wall Street is also suffering a very
volatile day right now and a lot of
people around the country are looking to
you and other lawmakers to get the
nation's business done and in working on
an economic proposal that the president
wants how do you balance all that sir
well it's been a large balance and I
think I've been at work all week down
here we've had other bills on the floor
this week FISA bills and also now
working I was just on conference call of
my colleagues concerning our response
look I think you'll see a lot of other
offices especially next week we're not
supposed to be in next week you'll see
probably a lot of staffs working from
home probably and we're discussing that
right now
my office and make sure there are DC
office because your Wilson we're already
starting to see it a couple of cases it
looks like now on spouse on the Senate
side that and others so is it is a very
real concern we want to stop it in its
tracks this is why the protocols are in
place so we can identify those that are
sick isolate them get them better and so
that others aren't infected but in
dealing with also this economic side the
president made it very clear last night
that he is willing to help but he wants
to help in the proper ways simply
throwing money in this situation right
now without having a proper oversight
even Democrats last night in the Rules
Committee we're very concerned about the
fact that no hearings or anything were
involved in this we won't work
bipartisan together to make sure the
American people have what they need from
an economic standpoint but we also it
needs to be targeted to make sure that
the economic stimulus of economic
progress here is not simply just
throwing money in a problem without any
real solutions to making the economy or
helping those who need help well you can
assume the markets looking for a
solution because as you've been speaking
the Dow has been off more than 2000
points and we can now report that the
Dow has fallen to its lowest level since
July 2017 so looking at multi-year lows
here and I'll let you know that our
reporting from Capitol Hill as of this
moment is that GOP leaders McCarthy and
McConnell oppose House Democrats
coronavirus bill the status of the bill
is now in limbo congressman how do you
respond in this as well and mr.
McConnell again we need a stimulus
package but we also need something that
actually will work there's nothing that
we've seen so far that actually stems
this time simply putting money into
unemployment insurance when you have
unemployment unemployment claims that
their lowest these are things that you
work on as the situation develops we
needed a stimulus now that if it works
help small businesses make sure that you
get extended leave those are the kind of
things that could work into this bill
but right now we've not been able to
partner on this like we did with the
steam of the coronavirus package from
last week in which we provided funds for
the actual attacking of the virus and
the response to that virus that was
bipartisan over 400 votes there's no
reason why we can't do this today and
work on that as we go forward and I know
McCarthy and others has talked to us and
Kevin Brady and others talked to us on
the conference call about why this is
not a package that at this point we can
support but I know the president is
committed to finding something that is
possibly going to work in our leadership
is committed to working with a Democrat
leadership to find that markets will be
aware of that and I think we just need
to make sure that we have a focused
response and only that's what the
administration is giving Congress
congressman in fact you just mentioned
the the House Republican leader Kevin
McCarthy we expect him to hold a news
conference live in the next few moments
we of course will go there live to hear
what he's saying about these economic
plans about the health response as well
of course Speaker Nancy Pelosi expected
to have a news conference later in the
hour we'll go there as well to hear from
both sides you're laying out the
important economic response and what you
want to see happen what about the health
response about a week ago you were with
the president in your home state there
in Georgia at the CDC headquarters and
we've been hearing from the
administration that they're prepared on
testing and then if you want to be
tested you can be tested for the corona
virus but a few moments ago Sandra
interviewed it interviewed Republican
senator John Barrasso who as you know is
not just the senator he's a doctor and
he said he still has concerns that the
CDC can really follow through on that
what assurances can you give the
American people this morning well they
sure said I have straight from the CDC
and working with the listing to the non
the president the vice president the
task force and watching this closely the
cdc's of course in my home state we
never forget this is the group that also
just a few years ago was able to get
under control the Ebola virus and others
these are not people who are honored to
customed to dealing with hard issues and
they're dealing with it and I think the
issue that we have now is is we need to
make sure testing is there for those
that are sick well we don't need to have
is rushing our health care system and
rushing the public health system with
folks who are just wondering if they
have the virus if you're sick you have
condition flu-like vision symptoms and
go get tested but I think right now if
the testing is it's ramping up the more
test kits are available we'll be able to
make sure that anyone who has those
symptoms are being able to be tested
I trust the CDC it's always as we look
forward to we make sure that it is
happening in real time
they're putting for the results I think
we'll see over time as that works out
but right now I
every confidence that the public health
officials all across this country in
every state are doing everything they
possibly can to make sure that they
identify the proper cases make sure
they're properly quarantined make sure
they're promptly being treated
therapeutics are being developed and a
long term me vaccine is being looked at
as well the big thing for people is is
to not panic in this but also to make
sure that they're doing what is
responsible and one of the biggest
things I've told people this for the
whole week that I've been here is some
of the simplest things are things that
sometimes you forget when you believe
it's some big crisis this goes back to
simple basic personal hygiene go back to
the sink you wash your hands don't go
out and call for people if you're sick
stay away and if you're if you are sick
make sure that you're treated those are
the ways that we can make sure that we
isolate this stop it it will continue to
grow but we can do so in at a much
slower pace than we've seen in the rest
of it a lot more about the spread of it
and how long can live in the air things
we didn't even know yesterday or a week
ago so congressman there's still a lot
to take in as you can see markets taking
all of this in this morning we wish you
well as you finish off your self
quarantine there and and Ted Cruz I
think finishes his this afternoon while
he's also shutting down his office now
we appreciate it congressman thank you
for coming on sir